bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here representing AZ man what are they
doing PK the poet what part of town are
you from 19th Ave you know what I'm
saying and from Camelback all the way up
to Dunlap you feel me so like 19th
Avenue and Dunlap is kind of Sunny
the Camelback though I'm saying
Camelback from 19th and Camelback is
different than the 19th and Dunlap yeah
but you you make an intersection
Camelback 19th and Camelback is a
[ __ ] wild place okay but it's better
than that QT on Dunlap what you talking
about yeah but that's like 19th Avenue
and like Hatcher no that's definitely
19. oh no no no there's no there's two
there's two because there's one right
before Peoria yes there's two there's
two right there there's the new one on
Dunlap you ain't been there in a long
time no there's the newer one on Dunlap
and then there's the one that's been
there that's right before Peoria on the
right yeah but that QT been there since
like before the Metro got there before
the low light Road got there the one on
19th at Dunlap has been there I'm saying
it's the newer one out of the two which
one's been there longer I'm not the one
before Peoria the one on done all right
the one on the one before thank you but
you ain't been there in a long time what
do you mean I [ __ ] them in Arizona
twice a month on 19th and Dunlap my
family lives in Sunnyslope what are we
talking about whatever bro all right
Jesus Christ PK the poet's here how
y'all doing Mr 19th Avenue all up and
down 19th Avenue is [ __ ] by the way it
is it is they but they building up like
luxury apartments yeah it's all [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] even if you guys like
Thunderbird and Cactus it's just like
[ __ ] in the white trash way damn it's
[ __ ] up yeah yeah anyway well listen
uh welcome to the show man we're gonna
have to do things shout out to uh
whatever you got going on plug your
music oh yeah black Hollywood I just
drive the Hollywood Noir it's an EP you
know I'm saying I've been pushing all
year shout out to my notes tape you know
so I've been doing uh dope [ __ ] Tapping
With Me what's coming soon what's coming
soon uh I got a show at the end of this
month for those that's in Phoenix
Arizona 27 check me out follow my
Instagram you'll be we at club downtown
oh club downtown yeah that's my spot
that's a great spot they got great
Mexican nights there yeah on Saturdays
they should be going up I heard yeah
shot my guy Edgar works over there all
right let's get to it man hit that beat
now turn that on
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
check me
check me
check me
hey I told him Kev look I said you ain't
gotta love it
hey
hey
look let me tap in
this is for healing myself this me
feeling myself jumping off the roof
[ __ ] [ __ ] is killing themselves cause
I'm off the top what's up boys is still
on the Shelf pour me in a pot and ditch
me out like I'm good for your health I
got time today day in line to hate
Barbara with a tear last year I gave all
the Fades worldwide Cuts Let It Burn
till it Usher Ablaze Drake put his heart
on the line I put my heart in my tape my
sound hard to Define yet I'm finding the
way learn the art of demise creators
that follow it hey wasted a lot of my
time hanging with [ __ ] that way swear
they was holding me down I'm much
stronger today healthy in the hood
Double Cup in my Accolade stretching
with a queen with a lean on Imma Stay
Center in my tea till it beam all kind
of ways [ __ ] in the say again hit
with it you be straight that's sunlight
grinding till I'm seeing a 100K like
it's some light Nas by the engine I
gripped the wheel like it's One mic I'm
passing you [ __ ] passing you critics
passing the block on past City Limits
pass me the auction passengers tripping
passing my thoughts like passwords
forgotten made a new link and everybody
copied get it for it still while
everybody shopping sentence to my
notebook Pages hold me hostage I'm
reading them out loud like an American
and bondage I tell abandoned drop [ __ ]
suicide my truth and I be fighting over
homage if healthy is my wealthy who
gonna pay me for my conscious opinion
not an option either Billy when I die
[ __ ] I drop [ __ ] or Millie to get me
rocking man I'm messed up look I'm
chopping bro [ __ ] you talking about
shout out to your IG so people can
follow me and PK the poor that's p k t h
a p-o-e-t [ __ ] with me I'm following man
you know what I'm saying 19th Avenue is
here tell them you know what I mean yeah
go to that Zia Records you know that Zia
Records that's where nip you know what
I'm saying pulled up we over there at
Eddie's go ahead get you some send me
some backwards over there it's a real
active liquor store on the other corner
across the street that liquor store's
[ __ ] anyway appreciate you buddy oh
yeah hey you just watched a crazy
freestyle and we drop one every week
sometimes more than once a week uh and
they're always presented by our family
at LRG now I love LRG I'm wearing look
I'm gonna just show you the new shorts I
got from them check out them shorts my
boy you know what I'm saying and got the
plain black tea the plain black LR GT
you know what I mean listen lrg's back
they just dropped the crazy Jason hoodie
with Jadakiss that's from like 2008 for
Halloween [ __ ] Flames go to the
website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg
30 off that's a significant amount of
money you're going to be saving when you
go to lrg's website Christmas is coming
save 30 off just by going to the website
and using the promo code bootleg L Dash
R g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle